jan ehlen nach unseren informationen was
uns die polizei mitgeteilt hat kam es
hier gestern gegen 1720 zu einem angriff
auf eine mitarbeiterin des corona
testzentrums eine familie soll da zum
test gekommen sein die es schon vor
mehreren tagen hier in tegel gelandet
hat aber zuerst auf den test der pflicht
verzichtet und wollte sich dann gestern
hier testen das sind die zeit von 72
stunden in der man sich dann testen
lassen kann war aber schon abgelaufen
deswegen wurden sie hier abgewiesen das
fangen sie anscheinend nicht so
prickelnd woraufhin dann ein mann was
sich der vater der familie die
mitarbeiterin die 29 jährige
mitarbeiterin angriff er soll sie
geschubst haben woraufhin sie dann gegen
eine stange gestoßen ist und sich leicht
verletzte
die familie floh dann und nun ermittelt
die polizei gegen unbekannt wegen
körperverletzung und ist auf der suche
nach der familie das testzentrum rudeln
gegen 18 uhr geschlossen
es ist jetzt mittlerweile wieder
eröffnet oder bleibt dass trantow märz
geschlossen
nein mittlerweile ist das testzentrum
wieder geschlossen wir stehen hier am
eingang in richtung testzentrum im
terminal d
die passagiere kommen von den von ihren
flügen und können sich dann freiwillig
dort zu den test zentrum begeben das
testzentrum hat normalerweise von 8 bis
21 uhr offen und wurde hat gestern drei
stunden früher geschlossen das hat jetzt
also wieder geöffnet wahrscheinlich
vielen dank peter wilke für diese
einblicke jetzt von tegel wo man sich
also wieder testen lassen kann
dankeschön